also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dieses
ding muss mich gleich wirklich umhauen
sonst steffel ich diese menschen für
komplett zurück geblieben und dumm
also reden können sie auch hallo leute
ich weiß gar nicht was hier passiert
etwas gebaut und jetzt willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja und ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut jetzt
wahrscheinlich habe ich schon gelesen es
geht heute mal wieder um ein ruhig
produkt um genauer zu sein so dass zwei
produkte falls ihr das letzte video zu
der reihe noch nicht gesehen habe da
ging es nämlich um eine drohne
schaut euch auf jeden fall nach diesem
video an kleine lustige story bevor wir
anfangen und zwar drehte sich heute auf
der einen seite um dieser kamera
die wollte ich eigentlich schon längst
getestet haben das video hatte ich auch
so weit schon gedreht ich hab sie
ausgepackt deswegen haben wir heute auch
leider hierzu keine verpacken mehr habe
sie dann ans ladegerät angeschlossen
gewartet gewartet gewartet jetzt
wirklich 24 stunden geladen und war
immer noch nicht voll war immer wenn ich
die abgenommen habe ich sie wieder
ausgegangen so danach ich schon im video
gesagt hey das ding ist absolut schrott
bis ich diese klappe hier gefunden habe
und wenn man diese klappe öffnet müssen
da einfach batterien rein ich dachte mir
in diesem moment wirklich so alexy dumm
bist du eigentlich das kannst du dir
doch auch denken wobei ist ja eigentlich
voll der widerspruch ist ich meine auf
der einen seite kann man das ding hier
mit laden und trotzdem müssen batterien
ein gutes bild zu erwarten das ding hat
elf euro gekostet glaube ich ich würde
sagen wir schauen uns das einfach mal
zusammen an lässt sich natürlich gleich
ich habe es bis jetzt noch nicht
getestet aber es gilt auf jeden fall
jetzt an leute also das hier ist die
kamera ich habe mich gerade vertan hat
doch 13 euro kostet
so sieht die aus ich habe mir die nicht
wirklich viel größer vorgestellt wenn
man hier jetzt mal schaut die ist recht
klein wir haben hier wohl 16 megapixel
1080p full hd und einem 16 fachen
digitalen zoomen also hat sich erstmal
gar nicht so schlecht an ich habe hier
dies waren ausgewählt also die gibt es
wohl auch noch ein bisschen besser
qualität so jetzt legen wir uns mal
schnell noch die rezension durch mache
ich ja immer sehr gerne fünf sterne sind
hier natürlich nur angegeben also was
ist wirklich so ein kleiner fuchs das
ist wirklich sonne hier oben kann man zu
den insgesamt dreieinhalb sterne ihr
werden natürlich nur die besten
bewertungen
seit klein fein und genauso wie
beschrieben nur eine speicherkarte muss
man sich kaufen
vielen dank wisch alle letzten
bestellungen sind bei mir eingetroffen
vielen dank für die prompten lieferung
sieht gut aus passt gut anhand weiter so
superleicht und genau wie ich mir
vorgestellt habe also ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen dieses ding muss mich
gleich wirklich umhauen sonst ständig
diese menschen für komplett zurück
geblieben und dumm ab gut ich will gar
nicht weiter beurteilen
das ist die erste kamera um die es heute
geht mit der zweiten machen wir schnell
weiter und zwar wenn ich da echt mal
gespannt was die so kann
wir haben hier eine wifi smarthome ip
kamera also eine überwachungskamera die
kann man wohl mit dem handy verbinden
und dann überwachen
theoretisch könnte ich dir hier in köln
irgendwo hinstellen und mir die leute
angucken wo ich mir jetzt so gedacht
darf man natürlich nicht aber halt eine
stumpfe überwachungskamera 13 euro hat
die mich gekostet vier sterne hatte nur
videos und fotos qualität bisschen
schlecht sonst alles perfekt was genau
möchtest du denn haben bei so einem ding
es geht doch nur um videos und fotos für
den preis von ok alles klar man kann die
wohl über 15 kilometer empfangen ob hier
wieso überwachungskameras genau
funktioniert weiß ich nicht ich hatte
noch nie eine so werde ich dann gleich
natürlich herausfinden 6000 kilometer
keine ahnung ich werde hier aus dem
schlauch also darum geht es im heutigen
video also um diese zwei kameras ihr
könnt mir jetzt mal produkte in die
kommentare schreiben
die ich auch mal für euch testen sollte
oder halt einfach bestellen soll dann
mache ich das auf jeden fall und wir
fangen jetzt mal an mit dem unboxing von
den beiden produkten also sollte das ist
die ganz normale kamera beziehungsweise
halt der videorekorder camcorder wie man
das auch immer nennen will ich habe ja
hier ist schon die drei batterien
reingetan hier unten kommen denn die
speicherkarte rein das ding kann man
hier auf dem knopf an machen und dann
geht es auch schon alles dann kann man
damit einer fotos machen wenn man hier
vorher drauf drückt und videos wenn man
hier vorher drauf wobei man glaube ich
erst noch den modus wechseln muss sie
haben auch ein menü da kann man einiges
umstellen zum beispiel kann man eine
reihe auflage machen man kann den
selbstauslöser einstellen also kann ich
ja gleich kurs probieren an sich geht es
aber natürlich bei den dingen darum wie
gut die videoqualität ist da bin ich
wirklich mal gespannt wie das vielleicht
aussieht weil ich kann mich so an einen
ersten geht er jetzt automatisch
nein weil ich kann mich noch an meine
erste digitalkamera erinnern und die
qualität von der habe ich ungefähr noch
ein bisschen im kopf die hat so 80 euro
gekostet wir werden sehen gut kommen wir
als nächstes hierzu der
überwachungskamera so also hier haben
wir die kamera stellt man halt so hin
hier kann man die wahrscheinlich
aufladen hier kommt dann denke ich mal
eine kleine sd karte rein dann kann man
die aufnahme mit denke ich speichern ich
finde für 13 euro sieht das relativ gut
aus das liegt doch einige ist die haben
wir auch ein mikrofon die werde ich
gleich mal testen mit meinem handy
verbinden und dann schauen wir mal ob
die gut funktioniert also wenn ihr euer
zuhause machen wollt bitte dazu haben
wir noch einmal hier das auf ladekabel
und und was das hier ist weiß ich nicht
genau und sogar noch so teile zum
anbringen und das ist der dotter also
das sind alles sachen die dabei sind
ich würde sagen ich mach mal pause und
versuch das mal zum laufen zu kriegen
also reden können sie auch ja nicht
schlecht so leute als nächstes muss man
die frau 380 app downloaden will die
öffne ich jetzt mal nicht mal kurz mit
meinem bildschirm auch von aggressiv
dann verbindet man das einfach übers
wlan die kamera ist mv blablabla okay
ich bin ich mit vier leute jetzt
konfiguriert er das hat halt irgendwie
ein bisschen gedauert
hallo leute ich weiß gar nicht was hier
passiert ich habe mich jetzt wie man
hier sehen kann schon mit der kamera
verbunden die auch wirklich extrem
schnell reagiert das ja krass alter die
bewegt sich die qualität ist echt gut
leute wartet marcus ich stell dir mal
kurz ins wohnzimmer und dann schauen wir
mal ob das immer noch funktioniert weil
ich habe jetzt mit mühe und not im
wohnzimmer platziert und kann sie jetzt
halt hier über steuern
ja das bild ist finde ich ok man kann
jetzt anscheinend auch aufnehmen
hierüber jetzt nimmt die auf da kann man
auch wieder aufhören und die kann sich
auch 108 so alter ja gut jetzt habe ich
mal die tür zugemacht weil die ist ja
etwas wlan verbunden ich weiß nicht ob
das jetzt immer noch geht
also ich habe mich damit jetzt wirklich
nicht lange befasst sich meine 32 rates
gekostet als funktioniert man hat ein
gutes vernünftiges bild und man kann sie
übers handy problemlos steuer deswegen
wäre hier mein fazit wenn ihr sowas für
zuhause braucht können dass euch holen
ist keine schlechte investition
natürlich weiß man nicht wie lange hält
so was aber es funktioniert also so viel
zu der überwachungskamera ich würde
sagen ich muss jetzt noch ein kaufmann
ich habe echt hunger und das blog ich
einfach mal mit dieser kamera
also es wird schon mal unesco
[Musik]
man muss sagen das ist echt ganz schön
kalt wir haben immer noch zehn grad ich
habe keine ahnung ob ich mich hören
können oder auch nicht
hier ist irgendwo das mikrofon so leute
vom einkaufen bin ich jetzt wieder da
ich sehe mich sogar hier
das sieht gar nicht mal so schlecht dass
eigentlich ja ich hab ein bisschen
eingekauft das war's mit dem video gibt
gerne nach oben
ich bin mal gespannt wie die qualität
her ist ihr könnt ihr eure meinung in
die kommentare schreiben
und wir sehen uns immer mal wieder ich
muss jetzt erstmals erstmalig habe mega
rock hard rain leute das video habe ich
jetzt schon fertig geschnitten mir ist
gerade aufgefallen ich habe noch gar
keine entrée zensieren gegeben vor allem
hier zur kamera ja mir ist eine sache
noch aufgefallen
die ich jetzt auf jeden fall zum schluss
nochmal aufgreifen muss ich weiß wir
leben in deutschland und viele deutsche
sind ja wirklich so ein bisschen also
keine ahnung wie sie hier sabine sabine
hat ja bei uns folgendes geschrieben
superleicht und genau wie ich mir
vorgestellt habe und ich denke mir
sabine was bist du für eine sabine es
ist natürlich wunderbar auch mal ein
schnäppchen zu machen und es muss ja
auch nicht jeder direkt 150 euro für
eine neue kamera ausgeben ja aber wir
leben im jahr 2018 und das sabine ist
der größte scheiß für das jahr 2018
gehen irgendein technik geschäft und
kauft ihr bitte dort eine kamera für 50
euro
die kann auch wenigstens was du kannst
mir doch nicht erzählen dass du hier mit
zufrieden bist superleicht und genau wie
ich sie mir vorgestellt hab was hast du
denn hier mit vor was findest du mit
dieser kamera sabine also da das ja für
mich komplett auf nahm ich meine habt
ihr wahrscheinlich gerade gesehen
die kann man von meinem opa von vor 20
jahren war besser als die ich meine der
sound ist ganz okay
die backt allerdings voll rum das heißt
ich habe ein paar sachen noch gesagt die
waren einfach gar nicht mehr drauf die
wurden automatisch irgendwie raus
gekettet oder das ist sowas bringt dann
ist der sound leider versetzt von der
videoaufnahme das ist auch ein bisschen
schade also an sich wenn ihr irgendwas
filmen wollt kauft auf keinen fall eine
kamera unter 50 euro das ist einfach
rausgeschmissen das geld dann gibt
lieber ein bisschen mehr aus und dann
habt ihr auch ein bisschen qualität gut
also soviel zu dieser kamera zu der über
das kamera habe ich ja schon gesagt ich
finde ich wirklich sehr sehr gut hätte
ich nicht gedacht dass man für 13 euro
sondern bekommt das dann auch noch über
wlan aufs handy problemlos stellen kann
man kann problemlos aufnehmen die
aufnahmen werden auch direkt an auf dem
handy gespeichert das heißt wenn ihr zum
beispiel heuerhaus ausstatten wollte und
solchen kameras ist das ganz klar
möglich ich bin mir jetzt hierbei nicht
sicher ob man die auch aufladen kann und
dann hinstellen ich musste den mann in
die steckdose stecken damit jedoch
funktionieren ihr könnt euch theoretisch
hunderte von den dingern holen sie ins
ganze haus platzieren und dann immer
auswählen auf welche gerade schauen
wollt das geht ganz easy über wlan also
das hätte ich mir irgendwie schwieriger
vorgestellt man kann hier auch alle
super easy steuert also das ist wirklich
ein zu empfehlen das ding für 13 euro
warum nicht mehr will ich jetzt auch gar
nicht mehr lava ich hoffe dass wieder
hat euch gefallen
gerne noch weitere vorschläge für
weitere produkte in die kommentare und
mir macht es einfach spaß was
auszupacken und ein bisschen zu testen
und das ist glaube ich mal ein guter
ausgleich zu meinem anderen content er
sonst keine ahnung immer ein bisschen
auf unterhaltung mehr aufgebaut ist auf
irgendwelchen inhalt aber gut so ist das
nun mal bei mir und wir sehen uns morgen
wieder da gibt es nämlich ein neues
video ich war gerade bei der bank habe
250 euro in münzen abgeholt und heute
abend wagen wir einen zweiten versuch um
den automaten mehr zu kaufen und das
kriegen wir hin
leute wir sehen uns haut rein die daumen
nach oben und nicht vergessen